hello everyone I'm really excited to
welcome you to this exclusive Xbox store
over Black Market one of the locations
in Dogtown that you are going to be able
to explore in cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty
as you can see Dogtown welcomes you with
an open arms
this is block
a location where you as a player as a
mercenary you can obtain unique
cyberware and weapons things that you
cannot find anywhere in this world
knockdown is a part of night City but
has its own very distinct look and Vibe
it's outside of the jurisdiction of ncpd
attracting all kinds of eccentrics and
dangerous characters
radical mods
in anything like that on a non-male
stroller
check this out
we have put a lot of work into making
the world feel more alive small scenes
secrets to find Easter eggs make this
place feel more vibrant and more
believable
but what's inescapable in Dogtown is
Kurt Hansen Kurt is a leader of borgas
militia who rules dock down of an iron
fists
in Dogtown I keep your business safe as
long as you abide
they're really nice guy as you can see
Black Market also is a place where you
can find new illegal weapons and goods
they are some of the most powerful items
in the world but are often much more
dangerous to use and use cyber capacity
system which leads you to push your body
to the Limit and give you new abilities
to deliver more thrilling gameplay
experiences like the air Dash or the
ability to see the enemies through the
walls change your appearance to lose the
Heat
Our Guest is the authorities of Dogtown
and they are more dangerous than ncpd
when you as a player commit crimes in
Dogtown they are the guys who are going
to chase you we have completely
overhauled the police system
all these actions are more believable
Dynamic and diverse the team has been
working passionately to deliver you more
deeper and meaningful experience and I
really cannot wait for you to find out
more this September
see you in Dogtown
we're not done talking about CD projekt
Red's next dive into the story between V
and Johnny just yet in fact we're here
with the voice and stylings of Johnny
silverhand Keanu Reeves himself welcome
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
likewise well Phantom Liberty introduces
us to an entirely new location in night
City it's called Dogtown it's this
devastated place it's controlled by a
militia but I think you know more about
it than I do so how would you describe
it to players night city has its own
kind of
levels to it and I think dog town is
kind of going down to a darker place
um
it's dystopian
it has attention to it and
this under current of kind of violence
you know like and struggle
you know
can I swear yeah shit's gone down
in dog town oh I like that tagline yeah
and it's just you know I mean hopefully
it'll be fun for people to uh
to play there
it's hard to believe that there's an
underbelly to the underbelly yes that is
night city right yeah a little scared
kind of drawn to we're all Moths To The
Flame aren't we and there's a lot of
flame and dark time well if anyone could
take it on it's V so that certainly
gives me the confidence yeah Visa
Survivor exactly oh yeah you know and we
just saw a tour of Dogtown too so we got
a little bit of that Ambiance and and we
can see what the environment is like
people are getting beat up it's not good
it's me yeah it's not the friendliest
place to be you gotta you gotta be
prepared for it truly yeah but in our
tour we also hear a recording from a
colonel Kurt Hansen who's this guy
because he seems pretty dangerous too
yeah that guy no I'm sorry I can't say
that my inner Johnny came out I think
that's good we know the tone now yeah
well I mean he's ex-military military
too ruthless power hungry manipulative
and Johnny doesn't like him I
could in general is the kind of place
breeds that kind of character yeah let's
take a step back let's talk about Johnny
as a person instead of this horrible
person known as Colonel Kurt Hanson I
don't know about this guy but people
like Johnny and I think it's interesting
because we know him to be opinionated
he's radical we've seen that in
cyberpunk 2077 in the main campaign but
as we get to know him he's got a
sensitive side too he can actually be
quite caring oh that's what makes it so
much fun he is outspoken he is a little
grumpy and he has a right to be he's
been used he's been abused he's been
abandoned and I think that through that
kind of hardness of his outside there is
a vulnerability to him and I think
what's great about it is I I get to play
that character in so many different ways
and so the range of it is cool
especially for the player you get to see
these moments in flashbacks you start to
understand he's a product of his
upbringing truly of his surrounding well
let's not get carried away mean I mean
we can start talking about nature and
nurture
I'm sorry I keep dropping into Johnny
but uh
[Music]
um
yeah I like I like his anger
I like his passion like what he stands
for he's
he's really just looking for a fair shot
and I I love that he's kind of going
through music that is an artist side to
him and
you know I got some great speeches
[Music]
there's all these moments with Johnny
where a tiny little thing you know
elicits this really fun response you can
flip him off and he double Birds you
back like I love those kind of moments
or Rock
I think another interesting lens of
looking at him as we get into Phantom
Liberty this is dynamic with Solomon
Reed so what can you tell me about
Johnny's relationship with Idris elba's
character I think Solomon has some
things in common with Johnny in the
sense of the military the sense of being
used abused
um you know it's in the title right
they're fighting for Liberty you know
Solomon's kind of trying to reclaim
his life
you know and Johnny's doing the same
thing you know it's cyberpunk 2077 so it
might start off as a revenge and it
might end as Revenge but I think
sometimes he feels like he's lashing out
at the wind
you know and I think Solomon
has been living out in the continent the
desert of his life right kind of hiding
and harboring yeah but I think he also
has that kind of soft and hard side to
him as well
so as somebody who's very familiar with
Thrillers because you've started in a
few
what do you think about Phantom Liberty
makes for a good spy Thriller in
particular
the quest to understand what's going on
so and and the kind of scavenger hunt of
information
the mystery the double crossing what is
true what's fiction what can you count
on you can't count on anything that is
really kind of Amplified
well thank you so much for coming out to
another Xbox presentation you've got a
lot of fans out there in the Xbox
community so I think I can speak for all
of us and saying we really appreciate
you showing up here today oh well thank
you
yeah well before I close things out I
love your help here at Keanu how do you
think Johnny would end this interview
right now
well there's a lot of ways you could do
that
Tina pleasure to meet you oh is that how
Johnny would do it yeah oh thank you
Johnny such a pleasure to have you out I
thought you were going to kick down the
camera or something so no you see he's
respectful you know you're you're a good
egg oh thank you you too and I'll see
you out there again soon